welcome to this video playing
international master f drive from from
the Ukraine I keep forgetting no he has
no name and that I cannot forget the
name because I don't know it okay we got
that b 3 Lawson's opening played this
Bishop d6 line always funky looking but
it's a this is the basic idea to at the
end get this anything interesting art
form I don't want to take really and
open there for you for now maybe form
this opens up the diagonal of course but
i still prefer that to capturing on f4
right h5m maybe this is some move d 5
i'm at this maybe Knight c3 here 93 how
do I cavity five maybe I can go maybe I
can do a six and after the bishop moves
97 yeah that that was also possible of
course with f6 but I'm not sure f6 g6 if
this is so good I mean it also kills his
bishop in a way and i have e file that's
that's that's quite nice maybe maybe
encourage him to take I really think f6
g6 is not so bad
I mean I have the better center I mean
central control as well something then
I'm not sure he will maybe you will also
retreat now nope okay he's not even
playing f6 interesting maybe trying to
get the night over first okay maybe 92
bishop asics this idea you can try look
F for each one is kind of this kind of
stuff when this could be tricky in fact
now this can be tricky
hmm ok um this can be can be a word
right now I don't see a tactic but there
might be something check here I'm Bishop
g7 yeah this is running right into
Bishop a6l I don't really know 1k but
this I want to do first get this on the
long diagonal Bishop a 6 can be the move
I have after week everyone if he wants
to play ruger phone ok so Bishop a 6 the
squeegee for what exactly
yeah okay can I can do this first to
make sure that nothing is appearing on
f1 okay if I take here and then play for
Luke f8 like that maybe rook f8 fighting
for the FL and they also have Queen a3
sometimes a resting in me or queen e5
attacking the knight the structure can
be tricky if an ID appears on c5 this is
not very nice but I'm not sure that he
manages this so easily when I get in
Luke f8 and remember i can maybe we can
get their file with g5 or something like
that okay yeah this is also very
weakening if I play Queen a three how do
out what what is he doing after that 91
maybe I don't have to do it at the
moment I can start with that oh this was
the idea
really didn't he didn't really think
about that now but the end game the end
game is no problem for me anyway like
rook evade I can exchange everything off
him check that's just good for blackjack
game my threat is to go all the way to a
three or to c5 maybe maybe if the King
appears on f4 this case may be yeah but
still I go all the way to c5 the bishop
is just the better piece here unless
very sick tactic maybe night a for
something like that this one okay at
least my king is not coming there that
that in that's interesting
I can try to get to deform but i'm not
sure that there is a way to the square
before it's no problem I can he can go
where all the way to c3 every don't mind
hmm he's simply not activating his skin
type warning deform can put put it on g4
as well yeah there is this unfortunately
no way to to to make any headway after
this after this deform I'm dominating
ass PCM but it's no way forward
night has no moves
King age 3 there is there is h 5
I bet you can move the night now maybe
and this this will be tricky with a
little time left Oh interesting so
knowing that and now you're in zoosk mom
now you're in zouk swung check still not
an easy win
no it's probably a draw on the position
I cannot I cannot make any any progress
iam it's probably just the draw right
laughs it's on time I offered the job
yeah it was too late it was simply too
late and as I could have taken the the
night iam yeah it was was a case where I
am I even I mean he blundered the pawn
loss does not even need to to do that
maybe maybe I should shouldn't play d3
here but it's not it's not a big
difference um yeah why that's terribly
passive of course but maybe am there is
no win because of the the totally
blocked nature of the position now why
this is really close to being Zeus want
the computer actually gives lines where
I win the Jeep on like this oh here I
could have one computer being on minus
five and I don't and I don't really see
how check how do I win here
I'm really not sure how I should win he
is having the King on g3 and I don't I
cannot promote the Jeep on and I cannot
go over hmm that's curious
and maybe I can can-can triangle late
and go to h5 that I need to I need to go
to h5 here like that and and get here
yeah that's that's the point that's
probably the point we get to get this
type of position and then i can actually
advance ok I didn't see that I didn't
see that I need to go to the H file I am
need to go to the h phone okay then it's
when I didn't see that in the game I was
basically just moving around yeah damn
thats that's not not good it's still
it's still this type here I can go and
win so yeah Wow tough very tough game
maybe I should have done something else
on C for him and not interesting ok
thanks for watching